[Music]
he took a pupda
on gupta
[Laughter]
thank you
that was mine add cnn to the list of
things joe rogan now owns
i speak of cnn's chief medical
correspondent dr sanjay gupta who
admitted to joe rogan that it was wrong
for the network including don lemon and
jim acosta to claim rogan took horse
dewormer as a covid treatment last month
rogan announced he test positive for the
virus and had been prescribed several
drugs to fight it including ivermectin
now that drug is fda approved for use in
humans for certain infectious diseases
and the formula for animal use is much
more concentrated but that's not what
rogan was taken but cnn didn't care and
lied about it and said rogan was taking
horse pills on wednesday he called them
out
they're lying at your network about
people taking human drugs versus drugs
from vegetables calling it a horse to
worm is not a flattering thing i guess
it's a lie it's a lie on a news network
you're talking about a drug that's been
given out to billions and billions of
people a drug that was responsible for
one of the inventors of it making the
nobel prize nobel prize in 2015-15 yeah
why would they lie and say that's horse
dwemer i can afford people medicine
this is ridiculous it's just a lot that
anyone is think but don't you think that
a lie like that is dangerous on a news
network when you know that they know
they're lying you know that they know
that i took medicine like here it is
this is ivermectin you got to sit right
here somebody gave it to me
all right hang on i i do the thing is
we're we're like going so fast
yes we are going so fast but rogan
didn't let up
do you think that's a problem that your
news network is not lies
well i don't i don't dude what did they
say they lied what did they say i was
taking horse dewormer first of all it
was prescribed to me by a doctor yeah
yeah
they shouldn't have said it was a bunch
of other medications if you got a human
pill because there were people that were
taking it the veterinary medication and
i you're not obviously you got it from a
doctor so that it shouldn't be called
that ivermectin can be a very effective
medication they shouldn't have said that
why did they do that i don't know you
didn't ask i didn't think that you're
the magnet guy over there i didn't ask i
should have asked but they did it
without such glee no i watched
i haven't seen a doctor get that
traumatized since my last prostate exam
[Laughter]
[Applause]
butt jokes work what do you know
now the takeaway here is that it's not
about the efficacy of the drug in
question it's that a network hosed a guy
they don't like and now that guy who has
a massive following of his own pushed
back and pushed back hard and now you
know why cnn's legion of scolds never
venture out of their network caves cnn
attempted to pick a fight with someone
with a bigger audience and a bigger
brain and got punched in the mouth right
back they tried to treat rogan like a
smiling kid in a maga hat he's not he's
a hyper-focused guy who does mixed
martial arts for fun i find it all to be
glorious and refreshing like when my
buddy sal feeds his neighbors
do you want some
e e
crunch crunch
there you go watch your head
look at this guy's sitting down over
here it's
crazy i
i love the ending
it's crazy
oh jeez michael so you've done you've
done joe rogan's podcast uh
joe's been like incorrect on some things
but it's not because he's lying it's
because he didn't have enough
information the difference is that cnn
is knowingly wrong being wrong about
this why do you think they did that
oh i mean they hate joe rogan because
they can't control him i mean joe always
makes this joke that he's the stupid guy
but when you're with him you realize
that his genius is that he's so
terrifying you really he's like a human
lie detector like you don't want to lie
in front of that guy yeah and you're in
stamina i mean you're there for like
three hours you're just kind of like
whatever you whatever you need to hear
from me you know it better be the truth
or you might break me in half yes
i could never do that i mean how you how
long were you on with him i was on for
we were on for two and a half hours then
he goes now let's talk about nuclear
power and i was like
i was like i'm out what do i need to do
to signal that you win
i'm tapping i'm packing that i'm tapping
now it was an incredible experience he's
a he's clearly a genius of the arts yeah
it's a it's an unusual thing and he
didn't even it's not like he actively
tried to do that kat the thing is i to
to michael's point i get the feeling
that like rogan is kind of like what cnn
was supposed to be like cnn was like the
news but it's not the news anymore it's
all ideology and now now you have these
two three-hour conversations where
people that was actually a good
conversation with gupta yeah so he's the
new cnn yeah and cnn is actually doing
all of the things or creating a lot of
the harms that it complains about uh so
they talk about this horse stormer thing
all the time because it's supposedly bad
they don't want people to take horse
storm or that's what they care about but
by saying that joe rogan took horse
dewormer because he's okay right yeah
they are actually going to be sending
the message that taking horse stormers
okay not the people who acknowledge the
difference between a human prescription
for ivermectin and veterinary horse
stormer yeah wouldn't it be funny if the
horse dewormer was actually better than
the human dewormer
that would be hilarious it would be
hilarious yeah but you know what's even
more hilarious is that uh
gupta basically
seems to me like a nice guy right and uh
you would think nice guys would have a
better defense against the truth right
but even nice guys like their paychecks
yeah and i was waiting for google hey
man i just got a book deal with them i
just signed a new thing whoa whoa hey
hey didn't we talk about this in the
back please hey cnn
he was literally on one of the shows
that they were talking about yeah the
thing about joe rogan that makes him so
special right now and it shouldn't make
him special is that he's being a
grown-ass man if you if you come at me
i'm going to come at you back and he's
even asking why yeah and they the goal
of cnn was to cancel joe the best part
of this the the the the side the the
accoutrement of this is that brian
stelter got destroyed
because he ripped we didn't cover we
didn't see it but he ripped on brian so
bad the last time that stelter came on
he had the lowest ratings ever he had
like six people and
three one of them was the post-its guy
the other one was like his parents like
he cancelled the canceler yeah so
that to me in itself is beauty yeah
because they got a taste of their own
medicine and they don't like it so maybe
they need some horse to warmer because
they're clearly full
i don't know why i'm going to ask you
this julie but i have a feeling have you
ever tried
veterinarian pills like fills out
because i have i've taken pills that
were designed for another species i
don't think a horse dewormer calling it
coat i'll never get the image out of my
head it's like i'm not kidding like
little white worms coming out of poop
yeah but um i i think it's also odd
that's so fun to talk about
i also think it's so very strange for
people to be getting medical advice
today if it weren't for sanjay gupta god
remember that wiping down i literally my
cereal boxes which then became wet and
soggy my wife would would leave the
groceries outside the house and we had
to take yes
yes and then wipe it down i left my kids
outside and had to wipe them down
i would just bring in the favorite one
and forget about the other ones i leave
mine in the garage just in case it rains
it's a little warmer there now that's
karen
that's still there all right my husband
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else